sameer when you're making a film that is
so close to everything that is about you
and has your family in it has your home
country do you almost see yourself as a
third person or how do you objectively
see yourself from another's eyes when
editing when filming yeah that's a good
question I mean it's always a principal
you know as a filmmaker are you part of
it or not because you are always part of
it you are influencing the scene even in
documentaries there is nothing like I'm
objectively you know describing the
things it's not possible you know if you
enter a room with the camera and already
you have an interaction with everything
if even the things in the in the room so
in the in this documentary it was even
really it was really heavy because I
knew everyone by heart and I knew myself
also of course now in my age a little
bit better how I get fastly upset or how
I can intrigue with charm or well
whatever you you know yourself better
and but you forget it you know because
you are with your family so I it was
very difficult for me you know -
sometimes I made even on my own the
camera so I forgot a lot of things
because I was so much touched
emotionally with with my relatives
it was difficulty I think it was the
most difficult film speaking of which
and I know you've made many films but
was it difficult for your friends and
family to see you as a filmmaker when
you'd instruct them for the interview
because they knew you in another realm
as Sameer the person but now you're
Sameer the director and so was it hard
at some times and you have to
we say I need you to stay in one place
mmm now if you have seen the film you
have maybe noticed that the reaction of
the people are different in front of the
camera and also how they use the
language is different you know like if
you would understand the average you see
my uncle in in in London which is starts
you know with the suit and the tie and
everything at the end he has everything
lost and even in his language he started
with fussa means the classical Arabic
you know and as more as he got emotional
he forgot it and he started to talk in
the Iraqi dialects the other one my
cousin Jamal in Moscow which is perfect
in English perfect in French perfect in
Russian perfect in Arabic in any
language
he was so much aware that I came with
the camera so he was the only one which
surprised me when I asked him so which
language should we talk you know that
was the only rhetorical introduction and
to the scene straight away he said I
want to talk English because I want to
be understood by everyone and everyone
in his mind is everyone the whole world
so so he started to tell me his story in
in English and my aunt in in in Oakland
she is more the emotional type even if
she's a doctor and she has always you
know if but when she talks how her
husband died she's in a very very
distant description of of this of this
happening and she later on cried not in
front of the camera but her story she
told me really with a very warm and
a very emotional way you know she was
laughing she was she forgot the camera
totally and and other one was my my
half-sister in Buffalo you know you you
have seen her everything is perfect and
yes
and she tries to control everything
because I believe that she was the only
one which really really grew up in the
total chaos
you know first her mother died and her
father my daughter my father died then
she grew up in in a huge family as an
adoptive girl and adopted girl with my
uncle then she grew up surrounded by by
the decline during the embargo in the
90s and then the war and the post-war
chaos and terrorist actions around so I
think she she is very strong and also in
her language she tried you know to to
speak you know so I was confronted by
not object they were all subject they
they it was not a you know a situation
like asking and answering it was not an
interview it was really that work was
much more close to oral history you know
of anthropologists even if I'm not a
scientific you know and I they were not
a tribe there for my family but I would
say the work was much more a work of of
an anthropologist which is part of the
tribe I would describe it like that so
it was really something different
totally different on everything I have
done you know even the last film about
the Iraqi Jews was very emotional and
because the man I found were the same
generation like my father my uncle's my
aunt and I had a very you know an
immediately
and a very strong tie to them you know
so it was a real bond till yet we are
still exchanging Samir do you make
movies because you love the process or
because you have to asking really
interesting questions in the first place
I always thought I I love filmmaking you
know when I remember how I I went into
this business I I remember I was only
one year at the art school and they told
me I have to go for drawing or for
photography and I refused
I thought drawing is I was excellent so
I was I thought this is boring to be to
be alone to be alone you know and a
photograph I missed I thought that's so
stupid
you know the world is moving why should
I take only a picture so I decided to go
and make an apprenticeship as a type of
graph because I loved typography
typography in general and writings and
you see that in my films all of them are
full with with any alphabet and words
because I believe words are are like
there are not only graphics there if you
if you use the right types you you
create an image which is much more
important than only the meaning of the
world however I understood them that I I
love much more to work with people and
so I worked as a laborer
in in the factory and I loved it very
much because to create things together
with other humans it I think this is
them the most beautiful process and
that's why we are humans
I believe that strongly so of course
there are exceptions great writers great
painters whatever but in generally I
believe I'm more that type and so it was
naturally that out of my interest I I
found my way into this business and in
the first place I wanted really to
create things together with others I
became a member of a video collective in
Zurich and we worked or everything
together until you know after five years
I find out that I had I had more ideas
to express things than others which
might more be much more interested in
you know lights or camera techniques or
whatever but we had the strong idea you
know as a corporate group that we should
do things all together so that was the
moment where I understood that I'm also
driven by formal aspects you know of how
creating things and how each they should
look so my first film I made with this
group together but I lead them to create
my own movies and they were at that time
all of my experimental stuff and it was
very very unique I didn't knew that I'm
doing something unique until you know
the art museum started to buy my stuff
then I felt okay it has some importance
but I I was not driven by that and I
didn't like the idea that I should be in
in a ivory tower
of art you know so so end of the 80s I
left it and I I went to to work with
with the TV on popular cinema stuff you
know until I created then my own company
yeah so it's I'm driven by my own
obsession that's for sure and in the
same time I love to work with people
together it's you know I was a radical
you saw in my film and I still believe
that humans should work together and
equal even if they are diverse how easy
is it for an arab filmmaker now to make
movies than it was let's say 20 years
ago I think you had said before in
another interview that they were bound
by religious restraint you know there
were ways that had to present something
yeah has it changed for them I'm I mean
I'm I'm in a privileged situation in
Switzerland I I'm belonging to the to
that kind of migrant kids or migrant
filmmakers which made their own way
abroad but even though it it was always
difficult to get money in Europe for
that kind of movies because yeah I mean
it's it's really funny you know I'm
representing Switzerland with Iraqi or
DC I believe strongly that that that it
makes sense because Switzerland is not
anymore that Heidi land you know which
is existing only with cheese and
chocolate and and forest this and legs
it it's full with migrants so it's it's
okay but the the most of my colleagues
in the Arab world are struggling hard
because it's really difficult to finance
these kind of films you have only the
chance to get a lot of money from Europe
because in France or in Norwich also in
Switzerland there are always small
fundings for the support of you know
filmmakers in Africa Latin America or
Asia but it's a it's a problem I'm also
producer so I always I'm confronted you
know with colleagues which are offering
me a new project in the Arab world
I have always to tell them ok you have
really to think over because if I'm
looking for money in in Europe we have
so many obligations to fulfill that you
have to be aware that your film will be
in a way created by neo-colonial
structures because the Europeans say if
we give money you have to take the DOP
if we give money you have to edit it
here you have to do the post-production
here bla bla bla so at the end it's it's
not it's it's difficult you know I mean
to create that kind of structures even
especially for someone like me which is
a wire about what is the meaning of this
you know economical structures you know
the who is empowering whom and all that
stuff so the situation for the Arab
filmmakers is really really difficult
not only because they have to fight the
dictatorship like in in Egypt now again
and in Syria but in Iraq York as an
example very depending to the Ministry
of Culture and which fraction you belong
and you know but one of the young
filmmakers now is living in New York and
the other one is is pleasing the
minister you know in Baghdad they are
the two most promising talents but you
see every one of them goes in a
different way you know
do you wish you made this film ten years
earlier yeah but it would not be
possible but I wish honestly I wish to
really dancing three
you why do you know yes ten years ago it
would be much more important to tell
this story the people because I I
believe if I would have told that film
ten years ago it might have helped
people to understand better the
situation on the ground in Iraq and in
the whole Middle East on the other hand
in this ten years the social media
changed the whole Arab world so
intensively and also in my own
reflection on on the ground I think ten
years ago my film would be maybe even
more depressive because now I see
through the social media much more hope
of change in the Arab world which was
ten years ago not so obvious it was not
so obvious you know but but the Arab
Spring in 2011 showed how a new
revolution will will be created and at
the same moment we are talking now in
Lebanon and Iraq there are organizing
the young people young artists
politicians and geo members through the
social media the biggest demonstration
ever in Iraq and in Lebanon against
government's against corruption and
calling for a secular government and
this is really something incredible and
it's a pity that I don't read that in
the newspaper here you know but on
Facebook and on Twitter I get every ten
minutes a message out what's going on
you know and and it's very promising so
I would say ten years ago yeah it would
be politically wiser to do that film but
ten years later like today it represents
much more the
the hope and the spirit of the new
generation in the Middle East